Aww yeah, I'm Ethan you're a life English
fluency coach and today we're talking
about one of my favorite topics.
So we are going to show you ten great songs
for you to learn English with and not
only this, we will also teach you some
great vocabulary, expressions and
pronunciation with the lyrics and
finally we will give you some tips so
that you can continue learning with
songs on your own.
And we'll jump into
all that in just a second but first I
want to let you know that if you're new
here every week we make you fun lessons
just like this one so that you can
understand fast speaking natives
without getting lost, without missing
the jokes and without subtitles.
Like Nadana who says that
thanks to our lessons he can now speak
English fluently, so if you want it too all
you have to do is hit that subscribe
button and the bell down below so you
don't miss any of our new lessons.
Number 10:
Your Song by Elton John.
Now, the reason that I chose this one is
because I recently watched the movie
Rocketman which is all about Elton
John's rise to fame now this was a super
fascinating movie and I recommend it to
you I had no idea that Elton John had
such a difficult life before I watch
this.
Now he is still considered one of
the top grossing artists of all time
which means that he has sold more albums
than almost any other artist alive.
Now, if you're not so much into older music
then you could check out the version
that Ellie Goulding did of this song.
But let's take a look at some of the
expressions that you'll learn in Your Song.
Number 9:
Paradise, by Coldplay
Now this is probably my favorite song by
this iconic band, let's take a look at
some of the great expressions that you
can learn in this song
Now this is a great
song to listen to if you're feeling a
bit down, that is a little bit sad
because it really lifts your spirit,
it breaks you out of your reality and get
you dreaming of what could be.
Now if you like alternative bands like Coldplay
then I highly recommend that you check
out Vera Blue from Australia who is
another alternative artist I discovered
this year and absolutely loved.
Number 8:
New Rules, by Dua Lipa
Dua Lipa is an up-and-coming artist who has a really
unique sound, now what this means is that
she is just starting to be recognised
for her talent and becoming popular.
Now we chose this song because it is filled
with really fantastic connected speech
to practice your native pronunciation
and understand that is better.
Now if you like New Rules another song that I loved by her is Don't Start Now.
Hey would you like to understand
natives no matter how fast we speak?
and wouldn't you like to be able
to watch your favorite movies and series
without the subtitles?
Well our Fluent with Friends course can
help you a ton in reaching your goal and
having a lot of fun along the way.
You will learn alongside the first two
seasons of the TV series Friends, which
various academic studies show is the
best series out there for learning
English.
And you get PDF power lessons
vocabulary memorization software, access
to our fluency circle global community
and so much more!
And you can try for
free right now with our three-part Masterclass.
What are you waiting for?
Just click up here or down in the description
below to learn more and sign up.
We look forward to meeting you inside.
Number 7: A Hard Rain Is Gonna Fall, by Bob Dylan.
Now Bob Dylan is famous for writing
ballads, that is a song that kind of
tells a story, it's like poetry.
Now this makes them really great for learning
expressions and figurative language as
well as how to tell a story in English.
You might kind of compare him to some
similar modern artists like Taylor Swift.
Now he wrote this song in the 60s about
all the depressing things that he was
seeing happening in the news.
However you can probably find a lot of relevance in
the lyrics of the song even today.
Now I actually discovered the song
because one of my favorite folk artists,
Laura Marling, did a really amazing cover of it.
Now if you like Bob Dylan and his
tremendous lyrics then I highly
recommend you check out some similarly
famous artists like Joni Mitchell,
John Denver and of course Laura Marling who I
mentioned before.
Number 6:
Were Is The Love, by The Black Eyed Peas.
Now we're moving to a very different
genre but not such a different topic.
This song is really an anthem for global
citizens.
Now an anthem is a song that
represents a group or cause for example
your country probably has a national anthem.
Now I like this song because it
talks about big global problems and asks
us if we can love our fellow brothers
and sisters of the human race.
It's also great to learn a little bit about
American culture as it makes many
different references as well as to learn
some great expressions.
Number 5:
I Don't Trust Myself, by John Mayer.
So now we're moving on to one of
my favourite artists of all time. I've
seen John Mayer many times in concert
and he is an incredibly talented musician,
in fact he's probably one of the best
guitarists alive.
Now this song that we've
chosen is one of the ones that made me
really fall in love with his music and
it's great for you as an English learner
because you can practice connected
speech and improve your native
pronunciation let's take a look.
So, one of the reasons I chose John Mayer is because he has done so many different genres
throughout his career.
Earlier he did a lot of pop, but
then he kinda transitioned more into music
that he was more passionate about like
blues, rock and folk.
So I'm sure almost any of you can find something
that you like by him.
And another artist that I
like for the same reason is Sia, earlier
in her career she actually started with
more blues but nowadays you'll find her
doing more motivational pop which is
really great if you're working out.
Number 4:
Rain On Me, by Lady Gaga and Ariana Grande.
Now moving on to another artist who has
experimented with a lot of different genres: Lady Gaga.
but most of us might think of her more
as being like the Queen of Pop.
Now one of the things that I really love about
Lady Gaga is that although she is very
unique she's not just a superficial pop star,
she is also a big proponent of the
value of kindness and she's spoken a lot
about this even with the Dalai Lama
let's take a look.
So, other than bein a humanitarian, she's also an extremely talented lyrics writer.
In fact a lot of you probably saw her recent film
A Star Is Born, which has some really powerful
music in it but we've chosen one that is
just super fun from her new album and we
actually did a recent lesson on it and
we're going to look at a few expressions
taken from that lesson and then if you
want to continue learning with Lady Gaga
I recommend that you check out the full
lesson after finishing this video.
Number 3:
Don't Stop Me Now, by Queen
Now did you know Lady Gaga's name
actually comes from a song from our next
band, Queen? Well I was absolutely
obsessed with Queen in high school and
it's so fantastic seeing that the band
had a renaissance since the film
Bohemian Rhapsody came out.
Now we actually did a lesson teaching English
with three of their songs which you can
check out after finishing this lesson
but right now we'll just look at an
excerpt of it to give you a taste.
So if you liked that then I also highly recommend
that you check out
the movie Bohemian Rhapsody because
this is really great to learn a little
bit about British culture as well as
learn more about the history of the band
Number 2: When The Party's Over, by Billie Eilish.
So similar to Bob Dylan, Billie Eilish's lyrics
usually tell some sort of a story, which
makes it really great to pick up some
different vocabulary.
However with When
The Party's Over we're going to
actually take a look at some of the
connected speech.
Now, this song like many of Billie Eilish's
is pretty slow and it's not too melodic
which makes it perfect to sing along
with to improve your pronunciation and
we made a full lesson with another song
of her no time to die which I highly
recommend you check out later if you're
a fan of Billy Eilish's.
Number 1: Lose Yourself, by Eminem.
Now personally I'm not a huge fan of rap
but it is one of the best types of
music to learn English because it very
closely mimics the rhythm of how natives speak.
In fact this is one of the songs
that I used to use to teach connected
speech to my students, if you practice it
over and over again your native
pronunciation will improve
a lot, I promise.
In fact let's actually take a look from
a clip of a lesson that we made using
the song so that you can practice
rapping along with Eminem and improve
your English pronunciation.
All right, so if you choose any of those
songs really you're going to have a lot
of fun and you'll learn a lot with them,
and English learners ask all the time
what are the best songs to be
learning English with?
Now really you should be
learning with whatever songs you love
you can definitely go learn with rap and
it will be very effective but if you
hate rap then you're not going to enjoy
the process, what's more important is
that you're cultivating curiosity that
you're not just listening to a song you
like but you're actually taking the time
to go look up the lyrics and really
understand what they mean and then sing along.
Sing along is so important because
it really builds those muscles of
articulation it doesn't matter if you're
a great singer just have fun doing it on
your own and as promised I have a few
quick tips for you so the first one is
to check out Genius lyrics when you're
looking up the lyrics at any song
because there you can find explanations
of what the lyrics mean now a lot of
times just by looking up the words and
lyrics you're not going to fully
understand because there's different
references to culture, there's different
references to something from the
person's personal life or they are being
creative with the language and it's not
exactly what it seems to mean so this
can really help you to go beyond just
the language to understand the deeper meaning.
The next is to use a website
called LyricsTraining now this is really
fantastic to build your vocabulary and
your comprehension with any song now
basically what they do is it's kind of
like a game they take out some of the
vocabulary and you basically have to
type it in while you're listening to the
song playing this is a really great
challenge and it's a lot of fun it's
very addictive go check it out.
Now the final tip is in Spotify or whatever
platform that you use to listen to music
create a playlist of the songs that
you're using to learn English because
then you can listen on the go when
you're in your car when you're in the
shower when you're cooking dinner and
you can actually be singing along and
practicing any time of day.
And finally if you want a method to learn English
with your favorite songs then I highly
recommend that you check out this lesson
that we made.
Now if you've liked the
songs that have suggested to you today
and you want to check out more of the
music that I'm listening to then you can
check out what I'm currently listening
to on Spotify I will post a link to that
playlist down in the description below
and I want to know what songs did I miss,
what are your favorite songs learn English with?
Share them with other English learners
by writing them down in the comments
below now thanks so much for joining me
today I hope you've had a lot of fun and
then you've gotten some new songs to
practice your English with and now it's
time to go beyond the classroom and live
your English, awww yeah!